y la lava que emerge de la erupción
volcánica del cumbre vieja la isla
española de la palma llegó al mar tras
arrasar todo en su camino en su contacto
con el agua provocó una nube de vapor de
agua y gases que pueden resultar tóxicas
para los ojos los pulmones y también la
piel de nosotros los seres humanos y
sobre todo por supuesto de las personas
que se encuentran en esa isla ya son
744 edificaciones que han sido afectadas
de las cuales 656 están totalmente
destruidas según el último recuento del
sistema de satélites europeos copernicus
para hablar de este tema las
implicaciones que tiene este volcán
cumbre vieja en erupción quiero saludar
al doctor jose mangas
viñuela el geólogo y también catedrático
de la universidad de las palmas de gran
canarias gracias doctor por estar aquí
con nosotros en directo américa en
france 24 le pregunto qué implicaciones
a grandes rasgos tiene todo este
fenómeno del volcán cumbre vieja
buenas tardes desde canarias por aquí ya
son la una y veinte
aunque no hemos comido todavía pero
bueno vamos a ver lo que me pregunta es
que este precio este proceso eruptivo
estromboliano va a generar además de la
destrucción que estamos viendo de lo que
son viviendas que ya son varios
centenares destrucción de campos
agrícolas porque es una zona de viñedo
con bodegas y de zona de cultivo de
plátanos y tenemos otros cultivos de
frutales claro va a ser una tragedia
para esta parte de la palma moderna y
ustedes en la imagen ven que está
bastante poblado hay núcleos urbanos
dispersos y muchos mucho cultivo y
también hay explotaciones agrícolas
el volcán va a cambiar va a cambiar la
topografía de la palma y en este lugar
es decir va ya no va a ser ya no va a
asistir lo que existía una ladera
inclinada hacia el mar sino que lo que
vamos a ver es qué va a cambiar
primeramente se ha formado un cono
volcánico que ya tiene casi 200 metros
de altura que es por donde sale el
material fragmentario los piroclastos y
la lava es tan impresionante porque es
una lava que tiene casi 800 metros de
largo tiene 7 km de largo y de potencia
entre 5 y casi 20 metros de altura decís
como si fuera un edificio de siete
plantas ocho plantas y eso se ha puesto
encima del antiguo de la antigua
topografía luego va a cambiar va a
cambiar hay que imponer posiblemente
hacer nuevos mapas topográficos de la
zona y ahora vemos que ha llegado al mar
desde anoche a las 11 y un minuto de la
noche hora canaria entró en el mar luego
también va a cambiar la topografía en el
mar fíjense que ya el acantilado
original que está ahí ya empezó a caer
la lava en forma de cascada ha llegado
ya justamente a zonas intermareales y
submareal es de debajo del agua y se va
a crear un nuevo cabo va a haber un
nuevo cabo va a ver un nuevo saliente en
la isla de la palma no sé lo que es si
vamos a desmenuzar entonces todo esto
todo esto que usted no nos ha dicho la
información de todo el cambio
topográfico que va a haber entonces en
la palma lo primero que le quiero
preguntar
cómo va a afectar esto el consumo en las
plantaciones usted ha dicho que ha
arrasado con todo tipo de plantaciones
como esto va a afectar a los habitantes
de esa isla y toda la cadena de
producción ya se empieza a ver a lo
mejor también le pregunto un
desabastecimiento de algunos productos
también por el difícil acceso de llegar
al por las carreteras por los
aeropuertos sí así es no porque la lava
lo que nos ha producido este proceso
volcánico es que hemos tenido que
evacuar a seis mil personas ahora seis
mil personas están justamente en casas
de familiares en polideportivos o sea
hay hoteles que se dedicaban al turismo
que es donde están justamente ahora
estas personas y son seis mil personas
que están fuera de casa muchos de ellos
no podrán volver porque ya se han
destruido cerca de 800 viviendas
entonces cuál es lo que va a modificar
va a modificar la persona
la vida de estas 800 personas que han
perdido la casa va a modificar el estilo
de vida de los agricultores
las carreteras están cortadas el
suministro de agua potable con las
tuberías se han quemado las conducciones
eléctricas se han caído los postes de la
luz luego a esta zona de la palma que la
tenemos al tan bonita que se llama la
isla bonita porque es verde con multitud
de erupciones volcánicas pues
lógicamente le va a afectar de punto de
vista económica las plantaciones de
plátano pues muchas de ellas se han
destruido ya en el recorrido de la lava
pero muchos agricultores no pueden ir a
regar esas plataneras durante estos diez
días que lleva la erupción luego va a
haber pérdidas económicas muy
importantes pero no tenemos problemas
porque gracias a dios' europa con el
plan de emergencia que se ha generado
europa españa va a dar esas ayudas a lo
que es el gobierno de canarias y a la
isla del agua ahora cuánto se podría
tardar en recuperar todo esto si es que
habría una recuperación o simplemente
trasladar pues todo ese sistema de vida
que había en esa zona a otra nos usted
me lo puede responder mejor como geólogo
si es difícil no porque claro sobre esa
colada que se ha formado nueva y estamos
solamente en 10 días de la erupción
fíjese que históricamente ha habido seis
soluciones en la palma cide de que los
españoles llegaron a canarias ha habido
seis erupciones históricas donde hay
descripciones históricas entonces estas
erupciones históricas han durado 24 días
33 días 56 68 88 vélez y que puede durar
la educción un mes dos o tres o tres
meses y llevamos diez días solamente de
erupción luego e históricamente hay que
pensar que la erupción por desgracia nos
va a estar ahí machacando a los palmeros
durante varias semanas ojalá se
terminará mañana pero los científicos lo
vemos difícil no porque hay un volumen
de magma muy importante debajo de la
isla de la palma de centenares de
millones de metros cúbicos de magma
caliente a 1200 grados que quiere salir
y está saliendo y es lo que tenemos
entonces las personas que están
afectadas el gobierno de canarias ya ha
comprado 270 pisos y casas para los
afectados y muchos de ellos claro era su
subsistencia porque y los campos de
cultivo luego tendrá que pensar en ir a
otra zona de canarias el gobierno o
canario tendrá que darles zonas en zonas
públicas donde puedan ellos seguir
haciendo la vida igual que las
explotaciones ganaderas
ya se nos acaba el tiempo para tratar de
también tocar otro tema importante la
toxicidad de estos gases qué implicación
tiene en la población de la palma que
está funcionando muy bien el plan de
emergencias de
volcánica de canarias está funcionando
muy bien fíjense que no aunque se ha
desplazado mucha gente no hemos tenido
de ninguna víctima no ahora tenemos el
problema de los gases tanto el que llega
al mar que se van a evaporar los gases
originados por la evaporación del agua
del mar y tenemos los gases tóxicos que
que salen justamente por el cono
volcánico y con las fisuras pero como el
plan de emergencias ha decretado una
zona de exclusión que son de varios
kilómetros para la población alrededor
de esta boca eruptiva y de la llegada al
mar en principio no tiene por qué haber
víctimas que es lo que origina si los
que están trabajando los científicos que
están trabajando a cerca
y todos van con mascarilla con gafas
especiales y botas especiales porque
porque se están emanando gases de
carbono
de azufre de cloro etcétera y son
tóxicos me normal que se dispersan en la
atmósfera y alejándonos de ello pues
cada vez tiene menos efectos pues jose
muchísimas gracias por explicarnos esta
compleja situación del volcán cumbre
vieja en la palma ya lo dejo para que
ahora sí se pueda ir a almorzar buen
almuerzo de jose gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en directo americanos a
ustedes por la difusión que es necesaria
y no olvidarnos de los palmeros así es
jose muchísimas gracias
estábamos conversando con el doctor jose
mangas a viñuela geólogo y catedrático
de la universidad de las palmas de gran
canarias para analizar un poco qué
consecuencias trae la erupción del
volcán a cumbre vieja